[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis mais ils
ont l'air très sage ce soir il ne se
dispute pas nounours lui aussi est sage
et il n'a pas apporté son parachute pour
euro n'ont pas trop peu de bonnes leçons
je recommencerai plus haut va voir ce
que fabrique mirabel et p'tit louis et
revient vite car nous avons encore une
longue tournée à faire remonter sur moi
patron je saurai boeuf oeufs
[Musique]
il est gros il aime grosse mare il est
très gentil il est pas bon mais on aime
bien qui sait à vincennes
[Musique]
c'est une fourche à moi maintenant les
ondes depuis elle est belle et pâle
comme une princesse qui n'aura elle
habite le ciel et ne se montre que la
nuit
qui sait si ni tong on nettoie le
support ou écouter écouter
[Musique]
c'est la lune
il est blanc ont le même endemol et on
le boit tous les matins qui sert aux
bosses ou là on ne te seront enfin sur
la vie dans un salle des canards et si
l'accord n'est sûrement pas il joue on
le met dans une cage et shon très bien à
moi à moi on se cache dessous
quand on joue à cache cache et on se
couche dessus quand on fait dodo qui
sert
[Musique]
encore une devinette cause oui mais la
dernière
il est sur un nuage et le jour du pipeau
il a du sable dans son sac et il
m'appelle allons les enfants il faut que
je m'en aille
sinon il y sera encore me gronder au
revoir watkins a démarré dès maintenant
[Musique]
bonnet mes enfants est très joli rêve
embrassez vos parents et allez vite vous
coucher ouais
bonsoir mirabel bonsoir petit louis bros
soir madame la lune à bientôt allons en
route fidèle compagnon route
à demain
[Musique]